I think if we could take one thing away
from this interview is that the girl
loves her eggs hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're going to be taking a look at
everything that Florence Pugh eats in a
day but first let me tell you what my
sponsor cook Unity so as a food blogger
and cookbook author I spent a lot of
time in the kitchen but I'm also a busy
Mama too and a business owner so there
are a lot of days when I just can't
sometimes I don't have the inspiration
sometimes I don't have the time
sometimes I don't have the ingredients
and sometimes I just don't have the
drive so when we're down south in the
states we always stock up on some of the
creative signature meals from cook Unity
cook Unity has over 50 talented chefs
from some of the best restaurants in the
country working at a regional micro
kitchens instead of massive production
facilities so you feel like you're
getting a restaurant meal at home
basically you let them know what you
like and what you don't like and you
pick a flexible meal plan so you can get
as few as four or as many as 16 meals
per week then you can select from
hundreds of meals that align with your
preferences and dietary restrictions
including things like vegan keto
gluten-free low sodium and more and they
use all really high quality chef-driven
ingredients the meals are delivered
fresh not frozen in compostable
recyclable or reusable packaging along
with expiration dates heating
instructions and nutrition stats and
then a few days before your delivery you
get a text to make your selections for
the next week it feels like one huge big
thing off my plate that I just can't
screw up the red wine braised short ribs
by Chef Mark forgione are amazing and
the menu rotates so often with a wide
range of different cultural flavors and
preparations so it really helps to fill
the gaps with inspiring fun meals for
those nights when things get super
hectic so if you want to try out cook
Unity for yourself go to cookunity.com
Abby or click the link in my description
and use my code abbey50 to get 50 off of
your first order of meals and you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are not already subscribed here hit that
subscribe button and follow me over on
Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen alright let's see what Florence
eats in a Day first of all I have to
wake up and make myself a tea I can't
have anything before I've had my tea I
have a Yorkshire Tea with oat milk and I
tend to leave the bag in I know lots of
people are going to hate me and then I
put the milk in and I kind of give it a
good brew and that way you get a nice
thickness to it so it's like a bit of a
stew my own British mum give me a real
hard time for even making tea in a
teacup like that and not actually
putting into a proper teapot that's
2022. I'm of the belief that everyone's
morning ritual is sacred so Florence
likes her tea Stewie I am here for
Stewie tea morning morning morning
morning
usually for brekkie I'll do at least two
boiled eggs they'll be medium to
hard-boiled so I'm thinking like four
and a half minutes five minutes I want
it to be a little bit gooey not too
gooey not any runny white and some salt
on the side and then a black coffee I'll
have a black a black Americana now I
love me some eggs in the morning no
matter how you slice it whether it's
scrambled poached fried baked boiled
come one come all and one of the things
I love about eggs in the morning is that
the protein quality helps to improve
satiety and keep you feeling Fuller for
longer in fact research shows that a
high protein breakfast helps to regulate
your appetite throughout the day and
this may be why Florence Feels So
Satisfied from just having two eggs in
the morning and maybe nothing on the
side however I do want to note that two
eggs only really provides around 150
calories so most of us would probably
need more food in the morning to get us
through the day not to mention front
loading more of our calories and carbs
earlier on in the day does seem to have
some hormonal and metabolic benefits as
well obviously I get that some folks
genuinely just don't have an appetite in
the morning so I would say as long as
we're still getting enough calories
later on in the day to make up for it no
harm no foul I grab and go sometimes a
I'll make a smoothie like either a
protein banana like make it Jazzy with
some leaves and some spinach stuff or
I'll just take a protein bar and have it
with my black coffee a morning smoothie
can definitely be a convenient breakfast
when you're on the go and you need
something super quick and easy and in
Florence's case we're getting some
protein from what I'm assuming is maybe
protein powder plus some fiber rich
carbs from the banana and spinach stuff
but I would say to really make this
smoothie a hunger crushing combo
breakfast we would also want to see a
source of fat in there just to keep her
Fuller a bit longer so this could mean
adding in some full fat Greek yogurt
some Nut Butter avocado or seeds like
Chia hemp or flax as for the protein bar
they usually contain anywhere between
150 50 to 400 calories so it may be hit
or miss as to whether or not it really
helps to keep her full until lunch same
goes with a smoothie as liquid calories
tend to be digested and absorbed a lot
faster so while I protein bar or a
smoothie are definitely practical quick
grab-and-go breakfast options and may be
appropriate for folks who maybe don't
have much of an appetite before noon I
would say most of us need more fuel my
solution have them both I'm a simple
breakfast person if I'm working if I'm
not working then I'll have the law I'll
I'll usually do what my dad does and
make like a half full English then I'll
do sourdough bread two fried eggs put
the lid on so it goes crispy underneath
it Cooks the top and then I'll do some
cherry tomatoes in a bowl pop them with
some olive oil a little bit of Balsam
salt pepper so I had to Google what a
half full English is but I guess it's
just like shorthand for an English
breakfast that requires less commitment
and I love her version most full English
breakfasts include eggs plus Sausage
Plus bacon plus baked beans so a lot of
saturated fat and salt and not a lot of
edge totally fine on occasion but we can
definitely balance it out to work it
more into our usual rotation I love
Florence's version because we've got
protein and family eggs carbs and a bit
of fiber in the sourdough healthy fats
in the olive oil and some micronutrients
in the cherry tomatoes I also love the
microwave hack to create like a lazy
girls balsamic glazed tomatoes and like
drenching it with the egg to make almost
like a shakshuka style breakfast so good
I would say if she had an appetite for
something like this on the regular I
would absolutely put this into the usual
rotation over just like a solo protein
bar and black coffee then on my snack
what I'll usually do throughout the day
is I'll pop into an m s or Pratt or Leon
or an itsu and I'll get one of their
little protein pots because they're
amazing and I'll either get like a
little bit of egg if I want a big lunch
I won't go for a little snack Bowl I'll
wait until I'm hungry because eating
when you're hungry is the best thing
ever I think if we could take one thing
away from this interview is that the
girl loves her eggs and I love eggs too
I probably have eggs every day but I do
recommend working in other proteins
occasionally just for nutrient diversity
I'll also say that I really appreciate
Florence being kind of like one of the
only few celebrities that seems to
normalize eating when you're hungry
feeling hunger is a normal healthy
biological cue that we really want to
celebrate not ignore we want to feel
some Hunger before meals because it
serves as a good reinforcing piece of
data that we're honoring our true needs
when I talk about Hunger crushing combos
or a food promoting satiety for longer
it's actually to help support food
freedom I really created the hunger
crush and combo because I was seeing a
lot of folks trying to like subsist on
these super small mini meals or snacks
all day long kind of in an effort to
keep calories as low as possible so they
might have like an apple for breast
breakfast and like a salad with no fat
for lunch a lot of volume but without a
lot of substance so of course we never
really get to experience the normal rise
and Falls of hunger but we actually want
to feel hunger before a meal we just
don't want to feel hunger all the time
because it leaves very little room in
our brain or our life for thoughts that
aren't food related it can ultimately be
very exhausting and triggering for folks
with complicated histories with food
hence why I encourage folks to try to
eat solid satisfy meals throughout the
day the eating process will be either
after like an hour of me making it oh
half an hour of me making it but I get
more excited about designing the thing
in my head executing it can we all just
agree for a moment that we are all
excited about Florence executing her
meals here I mean the popularity of her
cooking with flow series during lockdown
is evidence of that and it just goes to
show that Florence's relationship with
food goes well beyond eating just for
sustenance or fuel but also about
experiencing true joy and satisfaction
from the sensual experience of food from
start to finish typical lunch I'll
probably have like a late lunch I'll
probably do like three maybe three
Thirty so if I'm going for like a small
but really energizing salad I'll go
rocket spinach obviously wash them then
I'll go finely chopped pepper in like
little cubes and then I'll do cherry
tomatoes like the ones that are on the
vine obviously take them off the vine
don't put them in the salad and then I'm
gonna do cucumber loads of cucumber red
onion and I'm gonna slice it really
finely so that's all going in the bowl
and then I'm gonna do depending on what
mood I'm in I always like a bit of
fatter in my salad so I'm going to
crumble the feta olive oil nice olive
oil not cooking olive oil and then maybe
some rice wine vinegar or some white
wine vinegar and then if I'm wanting a
bit of spice I'll chop up a chili I love
the level of detail that Florence uses
to describe her meals and as for the
salad itself I love that we're getting a
variety of colorful veggies here plus
some fat in the cheese and dressing now
if this were a whole meal I would love
to see some added protein maybe some
beans chicken fish or even her go-to
eggs turning into a hunger crushing
combo will really help to ensure that we
can fully satisfy our hunger before we
get to that next meal my nostalgic food
lunch items from when I was younger my
mom was against all of the bad foods
that children took into school we were
never allowed to lunch balls we were
never allowed any sweeties I do like a
deal with my friend Chrissy and she
would give me a cheese string and I
hated it but just kind of like out of
rebellion and spite I remember eating it
in the toilet and being like because I
knew that Mom would not allow it this is
a perfect example of the psychological
impact of prohibiting Foods or
categorizing them as bad or forbidden
ultimately it just makes us want them
even more and we have evidence of this
in children where those who have been
restricted of a food will tend to
overeat it once they have been given
intermittent access and this is really
why we want to talk about Foods in
neutral language especially around our
children unfortunately a lot of kids who
are exposed to diet culture so early on
never quite escape and we know that kids
who are typically restricted or put on
diets in childhood often end up at risk
of disordered eating later on in life I
have a whole video on how to raise an
intuitive eater right here if you're
looking for some ways to break the cycle
of generational dieting depending on if
I wanted it for dinner usually I kind of
do this for dinner but if it's an
afternoon snack I make myself a cheese
board I'll get out of Manchego I'll get
out a crumbly cheddar I'll get out a
goat's cheese doesn't it doesn't matter
if it's gooey or hard or even if it has
like one of those nice crusts and then
I'll get some nice Quince out I'll get
some chutneys out maybe a Bramble and an
apple and an onion or whatever get get
all those things out and I'll make
myself a little cheese board with some
crackers then sometimes they eat that
and it's so Mega I don't have dinner I
don't mind I'll just have more of the
cheese this girl is speaking my love
language and that love language is
cheese when I was growing up we used to
call this kind of dinner a cold plate
dinner and honestly it was always like
one of our faves and I think it's
actually a pretty solid meal we got
protein and fat from the cheese some
Fiber and micronutrients from the fruit
plus some carbs in the crackers it's
easy it's interactive and it is super
fun and delicious I'm gonna get Dad to
cook me his famous roast chicken with
his potatoes and chorizo and his
vegetables this meal sounds like pure
comfort and it probably feels just like
a warm hug from your dad we are getting
all the works here with the protein and
fat from the chicken and chorizo carbs
in the potatoes and fiber in the veg
plus some gravy for some extra fat and
flavor I also just love the way that
Florence describes food like it's sticky
crispy gooey energizing it's not clean
or Locale or low fat when we focus on
the sensory elements of food rather than
external data like calories or portions
we can tune into our true needs and
desires and know when these needs have
been met oh I love like a rhubarb tarty
thing I love like something sweet and
sour and crispy with a bit of ice cream
on the side but I can kind of go without
dessert which is a shame because I love
ice cream but I'm more about the cheese
I also love tart rhubarb as well and in
fact one thing I learned when I honed my
intuitive eating skills was that I
actually didn't even love sweet things
like I used to be obsessed with sweets I
just had such a sweet tooth I feel like
I could eat them until I was sick but
the more opportunities that I gave
myself to eat what I actually wanted the
more I realized that a lot of the bad
foods that I was binging on wasn't even
something that I really wanted and that
just goes to show what can happen when
we truly start to invest in learning
about our body
um strange food
habits hmm I tend to put Marmite with a
lot of things like I feel like if you're
snacking you can just wipe a bit of
Marmite on the plate and anything you
chop up with Marmite will taste good if
I don't have anything to dip into peanut
butter I'll chop up a few carrots and
carrots and peanut butter is actually
quite nice Marmite seems like one of
those foods to either love it or you
hate it so sound off in the comments
with your thoughts but speaking from a
nutrition perspective Marmite is
actually an excellent source of B
vitamins like B12 thiamin niacin and
riboflavin and in fact one teaspoon of
Marmite provides around 25 percent of
the daily recommendation for B12 so it's
a great option for our plant-based folks
as for the carrot and peanut butter
combo I mean I guess it's not that
dissimilar to like the classic ants on a
log situation so honestly no judgment
for me on some of these favorite food
combos I have way weirder food combos
that I like best place for food in the
world Greek cuisine I love the family
style essence of it I love how it's like
one pot cooking the vegetables that
they've grown in their garden and any
animal that they use on them on the menu
they've either grown or they've either
sorted out themselves I love the idea of
a very simple salad with a very simple
stefada or musaka or something like that
I really love that it's the grannies in
the kitchen cooking and you can taste
all of the love and the heaven coming
down into that meal if this girl was not
successful Academy award-nominated
actress I am quite confident that she
would be a food writer because the way
that she romanticizes food is sexy as
[ __ ] and I also have to agree on the
Greek food like Greek food is inherently
delicious and very well balanced it's a
great example of the Mediterranean diet
which we actually have ample evidence to
support for lowering the risk of chronic
diseases like metabolic syndrome heart
disease diabetes and inflammation so
let's call this diet recall like it is
probably one of the most supportive
examples of celebrities diet the Harvest
Bazaar has ever published I think that
Publications like Harper's Bazaar do
have a responsibility to viewers to like
screen these interviews and determine if
they're problematic or super restrictive
and at the very least like issue a
trigger warning or disclaimer so I'm
always so jazzed to see a celebrity with
a non-diet supportive relationship with
food on this platform and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what if you'd like to
see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye foreign
[Music]